good morning hank we're at the louvre
and with the help of my intrepid spouse
we're going to determine which artists
have seen a baby at first we weren't
sure how to get to the louvre but we
figured it out from context clues and
after marveling at the crowd for a
moment we dove right in to determine
which artists have seen a baby which
this artist totally has and this artist
totally hasn't and yes i know that
cherubs are not technically babies but
we all know that in order to make a good
cherub you need to have seen a baby
which sadly this artist has not this
ancient sculptor has seen a baby
although babies do not tend to have
waste so that was a bit of a weird
choice side note one by the way there
will be three side notes these ancient
greek and roman sculptures in these
galleries seem inevitably unpainted
emphasizing the texture of the marble
and whatever but in fact most of them
were painted often very brightly meaning
that our whole neoclassical architecture
and art thing with unpainted stone
everywhere is not actually
neo-classical
anyway jacques louis david has
definitely seen a baby really good baby
botticelli i think saw a baby once years
ago but he's never seen a baby throw up
on anyone i actually think paolo
veneziano has seen a baby and has seen a
baby more recently than he has seen a
human woman then i went into the mona
lisa room to look at the people waiting
to look at the mona lisa but fortunately
for me i'm not here to see the mona lisa
i'm here to see if titian has ever seen
a baby which he has lily renee also has
seen a baby whereas domenico bokofumi
most certainly has not he's never even
had a baby described to him he's just
seen adults and imagined that they were
once smaller this artist has seen a baby
or at least a black and white photo of
one then we have this fascinating
painting one thing you should know about
this artist is that uh he has never seen
a baby oh wait i feel a side note coming
on i can already hear the art historian
screaming homunculus homunculus which
means like man-child in latin and it was
this big thing especially in medieval
european art where people would paint
the baby jesus as simultaneously small
and a full-grown man here is a
particularly horrifying example with the
idea being that jesus was always 100 god
and knew everything even when he was a
baby and so we have to portray him as
simultaneously a tiny little baby and a
god man none of which changes the
immutable reality that this artist has
never
seen a baby i mean in 1515 albrecht durr
made this picture of a rhinoceros
without ever having seen an actual
rhinoceros and you're telling me that
this artist has seen a baby this artist
has also never seen a baby who are in
fact notoriously poor horticulturalists
also this artist has never seen a baby
because they cannot hold books above
their heads but this artist has seen a
baby because gosh they look good in hats
side note 3 i was utterly entranced by
this incredibly weird painting of a
young man holding a statue like the way
he's holding it is so weirdly loving but
the man's face looks like he just got
dumped or something i don't know if this
is a good painting but after all this
religious iconography and mythology it
was just nice to see a 400 year old
michael sarah cradling a statue all
right back to the baby art this artist
has seen a baby as has this one and this
one and rubens is so proud of having
seen a baby that he painted like 30 of
them but of course
this artist has not seen a baby and
frankly i hope he never does because i
do not think you can trust people who
think babies look
like this after looking at all these
cherubs and baby gods i was starting to
think there wasn't a single work of art
in the entire louvre that understood
anything about actual babies but then i
came across this painting with sweet
little babies floating in space
surrounded by flowers
slightly spirally but also lovely and i
finally felt like my journey had come to
an end an artist who hadn't just seen a
baby but may have even like held one
hank i'll see you on friday